okay people joining this live stream
this is one for live streams of the day
this is about the redesign of the
appearance of formal symbols and I think
we have all kinds of people here to talk
about this so the issue here is that um
in a case like this is that is this this
is the old version right
with all this dotty stuff yes change
this implement so okay fine so the issue
is we think this is Gotti so to speak
it's ugly right so I think what we
agreed last time we were discussing
formal symbols is that we would go and
try and use something like the something
like double struck or something like
that wasn't is that what we yes so so
the idea was to use something similar to
double stack we discussed the problem
that there are already some things in
the system that are typeset with dollars
track like the differential de reals
except okay and and the argument you're
making here is what this is a reference
in which they use dots it's only that
they use dots for under thought nothing
above that I can't even see is that oh
there's another right exactly so
interestingly they only use it under the
summation sign so it's indicating this
is a bound variable and then you have to
infer that yourself for this Sumanth
why do they bother that well because
sometimes this the summation contains
conditions like if you see the first one
on the next page so it has a condition
and you want to know over which ones you
are summing oh I see equals and then
those are the things those are the pure
variables so in other words this is a
way of indicating that they're really in
our situation that there would be sort
of a third variable in addition to the
condition okay all right fine but this
was just an example to show that the
dots have been used but only one and I
was wondering why they're having one dot
instead of two but would help because
sometimes we have the tendency to look
too much
I mean look more at the upper part of
the letters because they it contains
money from
or perhaps it feels less cluttered if we
just just one under that okay but the
alternative and we have design folk here
right yeah um yes to try to use
something which is I think well we had
concluded last time yes and try to use
something that it's more in the like the
double struck family or something let's
try to avoid going gothic I think that
really is kind of a okay so font people
what variants
can you imagine using for fonts other
than weights and slants you mean well
okay so is there some exotic thing that
we'd use like a back slant is that
completely crazy it's interesting it's
there are fonts that slant that way but
not as a result of you know the
formatting coming from an operating
system it's just part of the design
pretty unusual all should we look at
that for a second I mean just for the
hell of it just because that's a variant
that isn't um let's see can we have
simulate that with with image processing
anybody got an idea how to do that so I
mean if we take can we can we well here
here's a know how will we do that so she
area yeah it's a sharing can you tell me
what it would be shearing look at the
page shearing transform and and the
angle negative angle how much you wanted
to share I got to use this version okay
in the 2d case
shirring transform okay
zero-one is that term so I can I can put
that into an image transformation is
that right yes and what is the zero one
mean what does it mean is there an image
geometric transformer image
transformation so let's go sort of
backwards right oh so maybe it needs to
be the other okay so let's say style a
50 maybe use M okay oh come on what did
this do we need image processing folk in
here that is a great image forward
transformation why does it why does it
change the bounding box I mean we can
see what it's doing there but why does
it change um did you see what I'm saying
why does it why does it cut off the
boundary there what keeps it at the same
size image so if you padded the original
image you will get it all okay can
somebody tell me how to do that like
image pad yeah I understand anybody know
what image pad you couldn't get away
with just putting a space in front of
the M could you
brilliant now why did I the color in the
gate was wrong apparently okay well
apart from that very bizarre piece there
which I don't understand very well so
this would allow us so let's go ahead
and guess ok so let's just see what this
would look like if we go and Andre
what's the right angle to use any
thoughts not really I think you're doing
okay with the 30 degrees right now so
I'm not saying I love it okay so it's
just getting out for that they're kind
of amusing I mean it's not very
distracting in a sense if you saw those
characters in a in an expression I claim
they wouldn't be they wouldn't be
particularly distracting I would try 25%
it's the 30s a bit much
let's try 20 just for the hell of it but
I mean my main point is would these be
distinctive and would they be I'm a
little worried if they're too small
as subscripted indices might be that the
italic would be a bit subtle especially
on the eyes and ELLs well let's see how
that compares to the forward sheering um
oh boy
our livestream has has some posted a
Wikipedia article about
left-leaning italics are very rare and
Latin alphabet is where an
attention-grabbing it effect is sought
right well it's a reason to use them so
what would that look like if we were to
combine anybody know how we can get rid
of that stupid thing on the right hand
side there um try remove the space after
there I'll remove the space after it
will have to be trimmed we have to do an
image trim on the right hand side but
the thing I'm trying to do here is to
see what this will look like if we were
to actually put these into formulas
right so imagine one of these formulas
Oh can't we do isn't there a way of
doing can we do sharing on the actual
character here you can get the vectors
but right now still the only way that we
have is round trip in through PDF which
wasn't something I was eager to okay
what about just just for the sake of
getting a sense of what's going on we
simply rotate these characters even
though it's going to you know just tip
them by is is there an adjustment box
thing that does the adjustment box thing
only move it around okay so the question
for this you can just use rotate okay so
it so then for example for here I can
for alpha and beta I can just say
they're um numbers are already somewhat
slanted forward right well so I'm going
to say alpha is rotate alpha minus 30
degrees let's say right
and beta the same thing um oops I think
I need plus 30 don't I
how come it's oh because one is a
forward transformation one is a yeah
well look what the heck oh well it looks
kind of nutso but but you know that with
the und yeah you'd be better because our
our Greek variables are already by
design rendered in a slanted fashions
well I mean it looks stupid here but but
but that's because this is a bad way to
do it
right um will it be distinctive enough
I'm a little worried about the optical
effect of it somehow making you know if
it's peppered throughout half of its
tilted one way the other half is tilted
another way some of it straight it's
gonna look really chaotic well okay um
do we get Jeremy Davis in this meeting
by the way twice to get them please okay
there's also the issue of metrics I
guess I guess we will custom draw these
characters so we can build in the right
metrics for them easily enough I guess
all right so look let's try to simulate
we can try and do a better simulation
here but um if somebody else could write
this code that would be super helpful
why is this
somehow some dead dead here okay
could somebody else try to write this
code please for one of these yeah I was
I was working on something okay okay so
any other ideas so other ideas include
bars above and below things like that
what would be I mean so typically a you
know what about an underline do we have
an underline do we haven't oh yeah
underline I don't I never use this what
does it mean how did that why did that
not work is that is that a style option
yeah it is okay so let's try that for a
second here okay
well that's certainly very simple I'm
not sure if it says formal variable
particularly
comments from people hey Jeremy we're
talking about four variables again I'm
trying to get rid of the dot Enis um and
we were thinking about left-leaning
italics okay ignore the black triangles
yes
okay so we got let's enumerate some of
the cases some of the things we could
imagine okay so we can imagine
okay so there's left-leaning italics
which requires there's um underlining I
mean there's various kinds of I don't
know we could imagine dotted underlining
if we care about that anybody think
that's worthwhile that's interesting
I think the underlining we get from the
function is really tight to the
character curious how it looks if you
use the operating systems underlining or
we write me paste the algorithm for the
two dots with our own custom underlining
for these scale right so how do we go
which was when you said Dada the
underlining does that mean
no I mean the on the liner itself is
made of a bunch of dots the underline is
made of a bunch of dots I think that
would be well it's hard to get away with
with pixels on the screen but you know
you would have it would take five pixels
minimums to be convincing okay we can do
it like single dot or single underdog or
some double under that or we could do an
underline don't see okay all right so
let me let me just write a function that
ah look at that magnificent Sandra on
our live stream has generated something
let's see what it is and Sewer Liz
ah okay I can't seem to work but maybe
oh it's probably because we need this
things
you
oh my gosh why is there an improperly
formatted could somebody see what I
wonder if you need oh there's the
sequence you you need to see the
sequence you need another semicolon the
line back there
that's definitely amusing oh saying copy
the second one because it's better okay
ah very good and we have another
contribution here
I feel I feel a little drunk looking at
these well let's do the following what I
want to do is I just want to write a
function that just substitutes these you
know what I'm saying with with whatever
okay so so let's just think how to do
this so what I want to do is character
range of that and then I want to say
alphabet and I'm just going to go and
then I'm gonna say transpose that um
that's gonna give me that and now what I
want to do is then for this let's let's
use John's sheera okay and let's say and
sorry sorry there's one problem with it
it's a fixed image size the font size
didn't actually make a difference here
so you might want to tune down that
image size my definition okay yeah I
mean give me an image size that's
suitable for these characters because
I'm going to actually try and set it in
here like 10 or something okay
all right so let's let's go here um yeah
10 looks fine okay so now what we want
to say is map thread of hash goes to
share of hash to common -20° I don't
know what the 50 is doing that oh you
can just omit the 50 but but I added
that argument if you wanted to add other
things like you know like underline or
something underlined or something like
that
okay all right so this map thread oh boy
this is computing the shears right
shears are instantaneous that's not what
takes time it's running which it's the
in port okay so there's that so now
let's go ahead with one of these well
that one actually has if somebody can
generate some more dotty things that
have them that have dots for um just
have ordinary character dots so to speak
differential route reduce will generate
these okay alfrid goodness sake why
didn't that substitute so that because
it's inside a function of that shouldn't
no it's because it's a string not the
symbol ah look I just had that bug John
I just had that bug I click that I don't
disbelieve you it's it doesn't make it
easier to track down and fix okay I mean
this isn't gonna be very beautiful
because it's got baseline misalignment
and all that kind of stuff
Alfred God's sake
oh just silly bugs hmm-hmm-hmm well okay
let's compare that with something like
style of hash - comma underlined
I mean that's definitely a hella lot
less distracting than the dots you know
you know if this was rendered properly
would it be decent I don't know what do
you guys think I don't think it will I
look at that it looks really
uncomfortable to me what the underlines
no need the backward oh yeah no I agree
I feel drunk it's making me woozy I
don't like it at all yeah underlines
seem fine to me except for the bug root
you know crashing into the baseline yeah
yeah I mean if if we were to actually
provide the character drawings ourselves
we can so one problem with underline is
there isn't a good way to handle what if
you want to underline a formal character
or a block of text I know where I'm
saving this somewhere you have a
fraction that contains underline
underbar underlying character yeah SW
notes variables thank you
you
sorry what do you think eirick relying a
current formal character is it I'm just
worried about typesetting that has
horizontal bars already in it like
fractions will look really ugly to have
a underlying numerator and then be
underlined denominator okay let's try
something like this okay so let's try
let's just try for the hell of it let's
try
you
you
okay well that didn't
that wasn't quite as extreme
you
I mean that's certainly harmless I don't
know whether it's very okay so now
Eric's point is if we just take a I
don't know let's take a what Andre font
people what's a bad example J anything
with a descender probably but you know
just doing a over B and with the lines
and curious you know okay I'm fine
hey no it's it's not a bug but don't
worry when you see what you want to see
well actually the the closeness of those
underlines makes this look better yeah
it helps actually in this case but I
don't think the closeness of the
underlines is obviously horrible I mean
the P looks a little bit odd but you
know the problem is you want something
that integrates with the letter doesn't
distract from the letter too much is my
conclusion it's really quite I can
barely hear you I was asking if four
letters with the sender's if we want to
draw the underlying you know for these
specific for the formal variables if we
want to draw the underline beneath the
descender or if it's better I mean it's
kind of interesting that it crosses the
descender I think it's interesting I
think it's fine I think for the purpose
that we want this for I think it's just
fine I don't think we're looking for
okay this is a suggestion of Sanders
let's just try okay well maybe it's just
me but I really don't like that
underline q hold on let's just try this
for a second
I mean I guess you could also worry
about putting an over bar over it to
indicate a mean which is a fairly common
notation guys comments on on Sanders
suggestion here
it looks decent but you know notation
like that would make me think dimensions
of maybe that's not not something we
need to worry about well no I agree
that's a possible concern but the
question is really I mean okay look the
dots are just total losers basically the
dots are way too distracting well two of
them are what about it's just one on top
I that's not useful that's that's
Newton's flux in notation on bottom I
think it'll be totally dotty and
distracting and we can try it and I
think dislike least or the dot on the
bottom and yeah what about if it was a a
rectangle with rounded corners about as
tight as this one is now and it's sort
of gray because then it sort of
encapsulated in some way kind of like
what Pender is trying to do with these
square brackets you mean that it's a
boxed symbol basically it's a box symbol
basically with it's sort of a you know
it's pretty tight it's it's rounded it's
gray but it feels like it's sort of
something else it's not so young well I
mean what do we mean by a formal symbol
what we mean by a formal symbol it's in
a sense a protected object right um
boxed in yeah I wouldn't want that to be
confused with key characters yeah I but
I don't but those are none of them are
one letter right they're all SC escaped
did want to represent the key a well
might do this but I think that's a
different
end of the world from these kinds of
formal variables and also those are have
much more space liking what Rogers
suggesting yeah I actually I'm actually
quite encouraged by this one let's try
let me just look at something good could
somebody give me a bigger example does
somebody have a bigger example of
something with lots of dots in it
differential route reduce will generate
you as many as you want okay just tell
me what to type then type a function
you know like Bessel J pick zero X yeah
let's come acts like the Hut yeah oh
yeah that's pretty duffy um and those
ones have Prime's in them to just which
makes very hard to pick out the primes
with the dots let's try
our primes are pretty subtle too might
be something to revisit well there's a
bunch extra space around these things
okay so we've got that case so what's
happening we'll have to put two together
and I can symbol was tools for my
cutters okay let's look at that and in a
way we could sort of formalize any
character but then doing that box around
it actually yes which would actually be
better than I mean how its represented
internally is a different issue because
it's got to be represented using formal
characters in that differential reduce
they think that underline is much better
than than their boxing probably the boxy
approach is also an issue with slanted
variables we're not seeing them slanted
is that intentional or just an accident
done well okay so the question here
might be I don't know what will happen
if I go bonkers if we try and
traditional formless what happens to
formal variables in traditional form and
that's certainly an advantage of the
modification being done systematically
and not within the font drawing right
within the character drawing it's nice
to be able to let the characters change
the styling you know font choices change
I don't know how you deal with the
problem of like symbols though of which
well I mean right now this works because
these are letter like characters which
means that they can define symbols if
you instead have well as so there are
two ways to go
I suppose one is you could have some
kind of decorator wrapper around it but
then you run into semantic problems
exactly like the ones were seeing here
with their experiments the other is I
suppose you could invent some kind of
combining character but the front end
doesn't have combining character support
yet your point is if one wanted to box a
sequence of characters it will be like
using some more maths arbitrary it
doesn't even have to be a sequence just
an arbitrary character I mean how do you
box an arbitrary character oh no I think
we have a new font character that is the
boxed version but as you point out if we
have you know ABC all together and
they're all boxed they're all be
individually boxed and they don't have a
way to wrap the box around everything
just to be clear at the present time
we're just talking about you know
changing the rendering of the existing
well right but the problem is if we use
a box type solution if they're a multi
character formal variables I mean right
now multi-character formal variables are
going to be pretty crazy and dotty right
because it's going to be dots around
every character but at least it will
work work I mean yeah fair enough
well I mean so if I were to do this the
sequence formal axe formal why will
create the symbol global backtick formal
axe formal why with no pursuit you're
saying like to just say yeah I mean you
know anything which preserves the
unicode characters but just changes
their rendering is pretty
straightforward but anything that
doesn't do that raises issues of
compatibility and you know maybe even
whether or not it's possible okay so
look the minimal solution here is purely
to re-render the formal formal you know
these formal letters right so we've
agreed the double dot thing is just
disastrous right so the question is
we've got
you know the minimal case here would be
to use um Singla below yeah or I don't
think that's gonna work but let's try it
okay can somebody write me simulation
code for that I mean that that would be
literally what what do i do I do
under um under script yeah under spread
with you know the string isn't the case
now we use grey dots so you could even
style up grain so let's do
this right no no yes that words right
you want you want the dot first into
gray second just right yep oh yeah yeah
sorry sorry sorry
okay can I use an adjustment box to get
that thing closer Matt doesn't help that
those are kind of like drunk different
heights it's pretty ugly unless daddy
yeah it's less dotty if that that's
where closer it wouldn't be that ugly
that's kind of you know that looks
entirely decent to me I mean obviously
the fact that the thoughts are sort of
scattered light is making it hard to
compare directly with the under under
stress underlying they need well it's
certainly a very trivial change to just
you know you know chop the dots off from
the top it's Michael Hill does he have
an opinion it makes it sufficiently
different so if you know what you're
doing I mean John
take me to mock-up just be under maybe
we can be you can just that's five
minutes maybe you can just and that's
the screenshot at some point and right
now there's another advantage for the
under dot which is that it sort of has
some continuity with what we're already
doing now what about what about this
idea of you know switching from formal
to informal things I mean by the way do
these dots line up well enough let me
just try something here if I take a
bunch of these and I say string join
they apart from the descenders that
wouldn't look so terrible if we was just
the under dot yeah I think if you look
even a multi character thing would look
sort of okay it would yeah just just
just like put your finger horizontally
over the upper dots and block your view
of it so that you just see the
characters and the under dots and it's
not bad at all and the descender is okay
it's within expectations our live stream
is saying it's still 2.8 but I think I
think that the well we can certainly
let's just do this um another window
over
you
you
you
you
I agree that that's not absolutely
hopeless
I mean it looks a little bit you know
clearly there it has a certain leopard
look right but you don't normally think
of a Multi multi character symbol
alright more wise words commands - not
working well man - changes the font size
which won't affect an image right well I
have to say that really doesn't look
that bad I mean it looks a hell of a lot
better than those stupid dots on top I
agree hmm and as your example
demonstrates you're more likely to have
ascenders and descenders is that a fact
about I don't know if its effect but it
looks well let's look I mean the only
just sound is a GJ y on Y P Q I append Q
or other common on formulas
right but the dots over I and J are
silly anyway sure
you
I guess looking at the other letters
it's sort of an even mix of listeners
and dissenters
okay well alright look I think we have a
path forward now the only question is
this formal you know turning everything
into a formal symbol and so on why do we
introduce that why do we want to
introduce that because we wanted to have
a way of generating
oh that's right as an inverse function
that's right we wanted to have multi
character so what would happen if we if
we had a function called formal symbol
of ABC for example that would well so
you're saying it has to dot fi it and so
it would have to put it in the system
context and notify it is that correct
so what this would turn into is system
backtick and then it would be what if da
defy me in that case a single dot under
the combined string no I was thinking
mint dot under everything how's that
different than multiplying you know ABC
no no I'm saying that that it's
literally a character where the whether
whether it is visually it'll look the
same right well no it will have spaces I
mean yeah I guess we have X's now for
multiply well even without the
difference between the sequence a PC and
a PC being multiplied yeah I wouldn't
worry about that Jeremy I think I think
ABC multiply mean that's the problem
well great um
now forever your machine is gonna have
these slanting asses right it would be
replace the characters by by the formal
letter the analogous formal letters and
create a system contact symbol
right but it would only you can don't I
mean and then you could use those things
but only after having called formal
symbol of ABC to create it well no but
for example the case that we've run into
is for axiomatic theory um the formal
symbol is not a symbol so you couldn't
use it and say compiled directly what
you could do is you have to create your
post right so you could evaluate formal
symbol ABC which would create the system
back thick a you know formal a formal C
symbol and then you could type that in
and use it but then you know your things
will only evaluate correctly in later
sessions if you remember to reevaluate
formal symbol of ABC wait a minute in
later sessions you're saying it won't go
into the system context that's the
problem right unless you evaluate form
or some other things you know I
understand and it would have the same
properties as the current formal symbol
you couldn't make assignment it sure I
mean well yeah but as you're pointing
out you'd have to predefine it that way
look the case that we've run into is a
case in axiomatic theory data okay well
we want to define let's say the inverse
operator for groups or something where
you want to call it inv and we want that
to be a lowercase inv but we just don't
want it to be confused with you know a
standard user level symbol is this a
useful useful solution or not
I mean clearly we can simulate that
solution for that package although it's
going to be unbelievably painful
in other words
oh boy I don't think this quite works I
don't know because because of this issue
about the system context thing it wasn't
for that I think this would work to sort
of create a formal thing or not but why
do we want it insistent because the fact
that is using the formal characters
probably shows that the users role
indicates that users would not have used
this symbol before I agree I agree well
well the single character formal system
formal symbols are by convention in
system in whatever context you want to
create it certainly it's not going to be
protected until I mean there's a certain
security and obscurity because people
are not going to create you know you
kind of know you're doing something
funky just like there is a certain
security in the fact that system symbols
tend to start with capital letters users
can start things with capital letters
but then there might be a collision
right or there X dollar 155 yes that's
true right so okay so then the idea here
would be I mean maybe we can try maybe
Jonathan could try you know we'll just
define this formal symbol thing look
with with them with the you know dots
above thing it's just hopeless but dots
just below I think it's not completely
crazy I think we should try it with dots
just below and we should suggest to
Jonathan that for the ice-o-matic Theory
stuff that he tried using us see how it
goes see what I would have liked for
that inv is to have a single dot under
inv that would visually look kind of
clean you think of it as one formal
taunt what exactly is a symbol of an
operator
it's an operator well it's a yes but
it's a symbol that is standing for an
operator
the truth is okay the truth is the
current convention that we're planning
to use so what this is doing is okay we
are encoding all sorts of axiomatic
theories like let's say I don't know the
axioms of ring theory for example okay
which include operators that we don't
normally have okay or let's say I don't
know ring let's say it has a plus for
instance yes but so what we were
planning to do there was to and you know
any one of these notational things as a
hack but what we were planning to do was
to represent that as a circle plus write
in other words so that it is not okay
let me let me just a little speech lot
about notation stuff I mean like like
you know we all know that the the whole
question about you know function X
function X are the X is the same are
they're not the same etc etcetera
etcetera
there isn't a good solution to that you
know to my great amusement years ago I
look at this giant book the Hank
Barendrecht book on lambda calculus and
I'm like surely these guys have got
something intelligent to say about this
and no the last you know 25 pages of the
book is about this problem and basically
the solutions being proposed there are
absolutely insane and under all very
very very messy so I mean I think it's a
sort of a fundamental unsolvable ok so
anyway that's a preamble for the hack
that I'm proposing that we use which is
that the plus of ring theory will become
circle plus and we make the assumption
that nobody has assigned a value to
circle plus okay so similarly if we use
a variable if we're going to use F and G
for you know then we can't assume that F
and G don't have values assigned but
we're going to assume that you know that
then formal F and formal G don't have
values assigned so first of all you
can't assume that nobody has the same
things the circle plus there are
deserving
packages all over the world which have
assigned definitions to circle plus okay
well I understand it understand so if
what you're saying package which is not
system then in the context of that
package circle plus can be whatever the
hell it wants but we can't just globally
steal Super Plus this is John's under
dots and I mean there looks a hell of a
lot better than that I mean it's
remarkably much better than the ones
with over dots I think so too
seems tolerable doramas over dots is
absurd can you scale it down
maybe John could should save one that's
bigger
yeah just right-click right-click and
set the magnification of one I think or
bed yeah that's about right in a case
well it's certainly better than ones
with dots above I think it's somewhat
acceptable but I'm sorry back to its
eyes point okay so the only way we could
avoid this is by having some some
additional you know dotted circle plus
so first of all they're right we need to
separate separate their operators from
symbols right these are not the same
thing they have very different parsing
properties right so I I said to quote
the quote oh dear and blinking on this
name but I sense a great deal of
confusion here so and I know maybe quiz
a and I should have a second offline
discussion about can I just tell you
what the issue is with it okay so what
we are trying to do is we're trying to
return axioms for axiomatic theories
okay
those axioms are extremely formal both
the operators and the formal variables
and the constants are all you know very
formal right their names don't really
mean anything and they're making sense
so like for example you know in like you
know the boolean algebra stuff I've
worked on with us where the main
operator of interest is NAND right it's
convenient just to represent that with
circle dot sure but go ahead or so are
you assigning any definition are you
just using you this format right and
it's just full form right I mean you can
make the full form types the hell do you
want you could make it types it as an
inv with a single under dot by using an
appropriate formatting rule right so
okay that's a different idea okay so
your idea okay so let me paraphrase that
idea your idea is that the that the full
form of these things in these you know
axiomatic theories will be some hugely
decorated thing with all kinds of sort
of structure around the symbols around
that operated symbols whatever right but
your suggestion which actually we have
not considered is merely to have a print
form that does something different so
type in escape wheels escape reels with
capital or lower case or lower case now
look at the underlying buck Spock
structure you will not see a single
double struck now I mean that's the
input form I'm saying unform at the cell
delete the / input form and on format to
cell Ravens pop oh it's a template box
so you can touch them on if you're one
of these bizarre people who thinks a
boldface rather than a double struck are
then you can customize the appearance of
that thing right right so this is a
symbol it formats in standard form as a
double struck are and right there's no
relation between them right I could make
I could have made that format as a
little dancing mochi right so you're
suggesting the implicit suggestion here
what would you do though I mean remember
these things in let's say you know ring
theory or whatever the X's and Y's that
are coming out and ring theory oh well
there are formal variables that that's
okay we use form variables for that but
the operators there are completely
arbitrary things I mean they don't mean
anything it's just a formal theory right
it doesn't have any interpretation the
problem I'm trying to solve is that I
want lattice theory to use actually I
would love it to use pluses and times in
its display and to have something that I
can reasonably manipulate and reasonably
type in the you know an input form for
that you see what I'm saying well I
claim those are mutually without a lot
of work right hanging that you know
typesetting and parsing are hard that's
something a smaller person is even
harder well I know that's why we were
trying to get a el cheapo solution by
having the thing come back by sort of
hijacking some of our standard you know
operators and so on I mean right but my
my basic point is not assigning any
values those things sure you can use
whatever you want that's what its
purpose the purpose is to be able to do
formal things so for example you might
say I've got this axiomatic theory I
want to you know prove like reduce style
you know do something with this formal
expression I don't want to assign values
to it I would be interested to get you
involved in this discussion because we
have to kind of come to some kind of
closure here all right we're gonna we're
gonna wrap this meeting we've got the
meeting about annotations of gosh
another live stream meeting um another
live stream meeting which is starting
late but anyway um okay so I think we've
got a good conclusion here let's go
ahead and and just chop the top dots off
okay okay and and we still got to
discuss this formal symbol function and
the related stuff of that axiomatic
theory so that will need to be a
separate meeting okay with the
difference happy
but here it look at me a much smaller
set of people okay thanks a lot guys
thanks to the comments on the livestream
and those who are interested from the
livestream I encourage you to come to
the next meeting which will start in a
couple minutes
Thanks see you guys